i spoke with pfizer ceo albert berla and
i'd like to
raise with you some of the concerns i
raised with him
so one you already mentioned
i raised the concern that pfizer is
engaged in aggressive advertising
campaigns
as you can imagine he said no
what do you think
i think you're both right um i think
that the i agree with you that the
aggressive advertising campaigns
uh do not add value to society
and i agree with him that they're
for the most part legal
and it's the way the game is played
right so sorry to interrupt but
oftentimes his responses are
um
especially now he's been ceo for only
like two years three years
he says fisa was a different company
we've made mistakes
right in the past we don't make mistakes
anymore
that there's rules
and we play by the rules
so like uh with every concern raised
there's very very strict rules as he
says in fact he says sometimes way too
strict and we play by them
and so in that sense advertisement it
doesn't seem like it's too aggressive
because it's playing by the rules
and relative to the other again it's the
game relative to the other companies
it's actually not that aggressive
relative to the other big pharma company
yes yes i i hope we can quickly get back
to whether or not they're playing by the
rules but in general but let's just look
at the question of advertising
specifically i think that's a good
example of what it looks like from
within that culture and from outside
that culture
he's saying that we follow the law
on our advertising we state the side
effects and we state the fda approved
indications and we we do what the law
says we have to do for advertising and i
have not
i've not been an expert in litigation
for a few years and i don't know what's
going on currently but let's take him at
his word
it could be true it might not be but it
could be but
if that's true
in his world in his culture that's
ethical business behavior
from
a common sense person's point of view
a drug company paying highly skilled
media folks
to take the information about the drug
and create the illusion uh the emotional
impact and the takeaway message for
viewers of advertisements that grossly
exaggerate the benefit of the drug
and minimize the harms it's sociopathic
behavior
to have viewers of ads
leave the ad
with an unrealistic impression of
the benefits and harms of the drug and
yet
he's playing by the rules he's doing his
job as ceo to maximize the effect of his
advertising and if he doesn't do it this
is a key point if he doesn't do it he'll
get fired and the next guy will
so the people that survive the company
the people that get uh
raises in the company move up and the
company are the ones that play by the
rules and that's how the game solidifies
itself but the game is within the
balance of the law sometimes most of the
time not always
we'll return to that question
i'm actually more concerned
about the effect of advertisement
in a kind of
much larger scale
on the
people that are getting funded by the
advertisement
in self-censorship just like more subtle
more
uh more passive
pressure to not say anything negative
because i've seen this
and i've been saddened by it
that people sacrifice integrity in small
ways
when they're being funded by a
particular company they don't they don't
see themselves as doing so
but you could just clearly see that the
space of opinions that they're willing
to engage in
or a space of ideas they're willing to
play with
is one that doesn't uh include negative
anything that could possibly be negative
about the company they just choose not
to because you know why
and that that's really sad to me that
you know if you give me a hundred bucks
i'm less likely to say something
negative about you
um
that makes me sad
because like the reason i wouldn't say
something negative about you i prefer
is the pressure of friendship and human
connection those kinds of things so i
understand that
that's also a problem by the way so to
start having dinners and shaking hands
and oh aren't we friends but the fact
that money has that effect is really sad
to me
on the news media on the journalists on
scientists
that's scary to me
but of course the direct advertisement
to consumers like you said was a
potentially very negative effect i
wanted to ask if
what you think is the most negative
impact of advertisement is it that
direct to consumer on television is it
advertisement of the doctors which
i'm surprised to learn i was vaguely
looking at is more than the
advertisement
the more spent on advertising to doctors
than to consumers that's really
confusing to me it's fascinating
actually and then also obviously the the
law side of things is the lobbying
dollars
which i think is less than all of those
but anyway it's in the ballpark what
concerns you most well it's the whole
nexus of influence
there's not one thing and and they don't
uh
invest all their they don't put all
their eggs in one basket it's a whole
surround sound um
program here yeah uh but
in terms of advertisements let's take an
e the advertisement trulicity is a
diabetes drug a tub for type 2 diabetes
an injectable drug um and it lowers
blood sugar just about as well as um
metformin does metformin costs about
four dollars a month
uh true licity costs i think sixty two
hundred dollars a year so
48 dollars a year versus 6 200.
trulicity has distinguished itself
because it did uh the manufacturer did a
study that showed that it significantly
reduces the risk of cardiovascular
disease in diabetics
and they got approval
on the basis of that study that very
large study being statistically
significant
what the so the ad the ads obviously
extol the virtues of true licity because
it reduces the risk of heart disease and
stroke and that's one of the major
morbidities
risks of type 2 diabetes what the ad
doesn't say is that you have to treat
323 people
to prevent one non-fatal event at a cost
of 2.7 million dollars
and even more importantly than that what
the ad doesn't say
is that the evidence shows that engaging
in an active healthy lifestyle program
reduces the risk of heart disease and
strokes far more
than true licity does
now this to be fair to the company the
sponsor
there's never been a study
that uh compared true licity
to lifestyle changes
but that's part of the problem of our
advertising you would think in a
rational society that was way out on a
limb
as a
a lone country besides new zealand that
allows direct-to-consumer advertising
that part of
allowing direct-to-consumer advertising
would be to mandate that the companies
establish whether their drug is better
than say healthy lifestyle adoption
to prevent the problems that they claim
to be preventing but we don't require
that so
the companies can afford to do very
large studies so that very small
differences become statistically
significant
and their studies are asking the
question how can we sell more drug
they're not asking the question how can
we prevent cardiovascular disease in
people with type 2 diabetes and that's
how we get often this we're now on the
in the extreme arm
of this
distortion of our medical knowledge of
studying how to sell more drugs than how
to make people more healthy
you